no you don't you don't in hands off of
me [ __ ] I've never had somebody in my
face like that never had somebody but
their hands I mean like I've just never
had that and it scarred me
all right Kim you aren't coming back to
real houses of Atlanta after five years
away for the landmark tenth season of
the show and in honor of that I wanna
revisit one of your iconic moments most
memorable I won't call it a best moment
no are you ready for this okay
here we go I felt the need to tug on her
wig
I did not try to pull it off I did not
want to pull it off
I just wanted to shift it a little bit
yeah sure I had the audacity to pull my
hair I'm shocked and I'm floored and I'm
hurt and I just wonder where are your
morals and values she right your hair's
fake too
I really should have a makeup artist we
all should have two seasons we did our
own mess in that wig honey I swear I
didn't look like that in person look at
my eyebrows they're black lines why did
that think that was cute
I was meeting with somebody for these
like east cigarettes uh-huh and he was
with Michael Lohan okay at a restaurant
before us and so they went and dropped
me off at the filming got it
that explains why Lindsay like I've
never seen him again or spoken to him
that's the squashing move on what
happened to that Nene so you can be that
we talk be free of it what they're
pulling on me ain't nothing changed it
was bananas lived in O hands dad it was
there
oh he nearly drove me insane can you
believe after watching that that you
decided to jump back into that fire know
I often wonder like are you going back
you know is not I thought it would be a
lot more positive because I've grown and
right assume that everybody else would
grow and like this too short you know
so Here I am five years later and just
spiritually grown and mentally
emotionally grown and I just feel
unstoppable
[Music]